Hello everyone and welcome to today's
live stream where I'm going to be going
over some new stuff in Blender 5.1 and
just making a little project that I
wanted to make on the side. So, first
thing that we can see right here is that
I have a grid that is doing a volume
simulation, but it only has one
dimension using the new cube grid
topology node. Oh, also before I get too
ahead of myself, uh I forgot to check
when the Blender 5.1 beta happens. So
that's when new features are frozen and
they just work on bug fixing until it
actually comes out. So next th or this
upcoming Thursday, there will be no new
features, which uh lists will not be in
Blender 5.1. I thought we had more time
to work on that kind of stuff before it
came out. Uh I have some notes I want to
make for that but uh yeah there is not
enough not enough time and I did not
know I should have checked that weeks
ago. But yes, uh, beyond that, there are
some very cool nodes coming in Blender
5.1. One of them being the cube grid
topology node where we can just set the
resolutions and it just gives us a base
grid that just a boolean which I believe
is set to true by default which just
gives a framework for other grids.
So in this case I set the cube grid
topology. I set the transform so that
all the squares are even because the
advect uh velocity node needs it which I
forget if I even use that further down
the line. And then I multiply it by zero
and then I add to one of the smoke grids
because grids are their own they're they
don't need to be attached to geometry
until you want to set a material. So
this is just being passed along and then
I do the actual simulation which I'll
give a brief breakdown. This is from uh
Sean Trelli I believe the name is though
I could be pronouncing that very wrong.
I add to the velocity every simulation
step. I add vect to the velocity using
this setup so that it'll wrap around
borders as we can see giving that
infinite simulation look. And yeah
that's the advct setup. Multiplying
[music] this by zero on the Z because we
don't want it moving outside of the
thing. the divergence in this case I'm
using grid divergence but you need to
multiply it by like the amount of voxels
but I don't know the how to do that
exactly so just set it to how it feels
what feels right you could do it either
by sampling the grid floats in this case
you know you get the box index add to
end yada yada so you could do it either
this way but this way is faster by I
think a few milliseconds
uh for the pressure which happens
Next,
as far as I I need to find if there's a
official way of doing this, but for now
I'm just using the up down left right
you know add all those together subtract
from that divide by four and then you
iterate on that that is the most
expensive part of this entire operation
which takes which is four iterations 12
milliseconds I should mention this is
just a 256 256x1 grid and it is still
it's slow it's slow maybe it would
beaster faster to do it on just a
regular mesh, but since this is more
generic, you could just add in a third
dimension and it should be pretty much
fine.
Yeah. And then you subtract the pressure
from the velocity grid, which looks like
this. Again, I you need to divide it by
some sort of voxil count, [music] which
I'm still not entirely sure. This one is
faster compared to this, which you would
need to connect that for the third
dimension, yada yada, but you get it. me
actually go and organize this a little
bit better.
Let me move that down over to here.
Yeah, this is only using grids because
if you were to store the grids, it would
be less efficient. Uh and then here,
which this setup is just another advect
except add vecting smoke, but this is
terribly organized.
Move [music] some of the things around,
make it just a little easier to see. I
don't know why I'm multiplying it by one
[music] after the fact. It was probably
useful for something. Oh, it was for
dissipation, but we don't need that at
the moment.
So, that's the setup for that. So,
that's how the grid is set up. Uh, you
only need to output the the actual
smoke, the pressure, and the velocity
out there. I forget if you actually need
the pressure or if that's calculated on
the fly.
Uh, the pressure. Yeah. H. Do we even
need the pressure as the input?
Maybe. Maybe I could eliminate. We'll
just see about that. But we might not
even have to store that. Yeah, with that
we can see that the simulation is
running quite well. If we look at just
the grid like this, we can see it looks
like that. You know, pretty standard.
This part is real time until you try to
boxize it. I set the grid background to
be negative one so that the volume to
mesh doesn't flip back and forth.
As we can see, it looks uh looks pretty
good. And then I can volume it, shade
smooth, set material, and all that good
stuff. So either way, if you want to
mesh it or just keep it as volume, both
of those are valid ways of doing it. Let
me connect the volume right here. And we
can see that is working. And we can see
it looks very orange because of the
lights.
Yep. So 2D simulations, 2D volume
simulations, which apparently that is
pretty popular in Houdini because they
use that in for like height maps and
stuff like that. Options are there. I
want to try out more things like
temperature and stuff like that, but
smoke simulations are still quite heavy
and I do not have a super powerful CPU,
so I probably won't be dealing too much
with that. But it is very cool. I have a
vision though if we could use the
compositor for stuff like that, that
would be very cool.
Yes, for the moment it looks pretty
pretty cool. Uh in terms of other stuff
that is coming in Blender 5.1, let me go
and
get the change log so that you all can
see
Firefox.
It's
I'm just going to show you all the
geometry node change log stuff and maybe
a few other things
browser.
Ah, there we go. Okay, so for Blender
5.1
mix color now does that. Yep. Pack UV
islands now has
let me just zoom in so you can see it a
bit better. Uh let's see. Inputs to
define a custom packing region. You can
search for warnings. UV unwrap has a
slim unwrap option and no flip. Bone
info supports rebone transforms. This
will be useful when we get lists. So, at
the moment, you can get one bone or a
couple if you store all the names of a
bone as strings in an index switch.
Inconvenient. That'll probably be much
more relevant in [music] 5.2.
If I get the uh armature, no, the
attribute the geometry attribute node
in, which shouldn't be too difficult,
but I'm just going to wait until 5.2 is
actually going. There we go. The string
to curves has uh uh input sockets. I'm
hoping to get the word ID in for that,
which will be good. There's a new font
socket. Get bundle item, store bundle
item. Uh I'm just making a little note
for this. I need to fix the bundle
signatures in here, which is actually a
bit of a pain because I basically have
to remake the nodes
uh just to work on like the cuz the
signature just stores
it's only on the UI level. I thought
when I first made these notes, I thought
it would automatically get what's in the
bundle, but it doesn't. And it's a
little quirky with all that. New matrix
SDV node for singular value
decomposition for 3x3 matrices. This is
very useful for stuff like the rigid
body simulation setup for inertia
tensors,
which I need to try using that with
that. But there's still the collision
points issue. But maybe I'm smart enough
to deal with that this time around, even
if it's for just one collision. Not even
tons of them. New uh cube grid topology,
which we went over. New grid dilate and
a road node. This one, it seems like a
specific open VDB thing where it changes
the active box and like expands the
bounds. I'm still not all too sure. Uh,
the set grid background node has a new
option to update the inactive box
values, too. Uh, new grid mean and grid
media nodes. We'll need to take a look
at that. So, that's good. That's all for
geometry nodes, which is amazing. For
the compositor, the mask to SDF node,
I'm very happy about that. That'll be
very useful for quite few setups. Again,
I have a vision of being able to have
little uh compositor nodes and like the
shader and geometry node editors because
it can work on the CPU.
So, it'll probably replace the old uh
disabled the old and unused
um texture editor, but that there has
been no word on that. That is just a
vision I have in my brain. I'm not smart
enough to even try to implement that,
but it would be cool. Uh, index switch
is now supported. Sync sequencer strip
info has been added. Uh, I don't believe
this is GPU supported yet, but they plan
for that in 2026, I believe. There's a
whole lot of other changes in there, I
think. Um, let's see. I think there's an
option that's coming around where you
can disable the default
uh file output, which is very useful. If
you've ever tried to use the uh file
output node, it always store it tries to
output a duplicate, which is annoying
when you try to render stuff. I've had
to do that in the past. Yeah, there's
all that. Let's see what's up with the
Where's the shading.
Well, let's just go to cycles and see.
Okay. Yep, that seems pretty good. EV
and viewport. I'm now expecting planer
reflections now support glossy
reflections and refraction.
Ah, okay, that makes sense. Yep. AOVs
have been bumped to 128. That's good.
Transparency evaluation for shader to
RGB. People have been wanting that for a
long time because they had that in EV
legacy and they are porting some of
those options. HDRI HDRI uh light path
node.
I did back support for the light path
node inside the world node tree. Oh,
another thing for me legacy coming back.
It's good to see that. Uh let's see.
overlay to oh the overlay the
performance overlay that is pretty cool.
Let's take a look at that.
Okay. So let's actually take a look at
the pull request.
So you can see the evaluation
synchronization and total times which
let's see I forget which one does which.
I think evaluation is like the CPU side.
The synchronization is like the GPU side
but I could be very wrong. But this will
be very useful when debugging stuff.
So you can see the performance right
there and that will be very very good.
Thank you very much to Pulk David for
that. That will be extremely useful when
debugging why Eevee next is um
slowing down.
Does that um does that work for cycles
too or I assume that's only Eevee.
Okay. Okay. Even materials are compiled
by pre Oh, wait. No, this is Yeah, it's
for the overlay. Yeah. No, but maybe it
works for both. H, I'll need to look
into that.
Uh, even materials are compiled faster
by pre-ompiling GPU pipelines at the
same time. GPU shaders compile faster on
all platforms due to pre-processing the
shader sources. So, we can see that.
See, it goes down. Oh, yeah. No, that's
actually
it's a little more expensive when it's
warm versus cold
then on Vulcan. It's Yeah, just a little
more expensive there. But it is much
better when it's pre-ompiled. That's
good. That's very good.
Uh grease pencil. Let's just let's just
go through all of them before I do my
little shader project that I want to
try. Uh let's see. Move to layer. There
we go. Me parent. Okay. All that seems
to be good. Going over this very fast
snapping curves and then the boolean
exact solver can be significantly faster
with many attributes with manifold. Oh,
that's cool. Support for that that that
vertx slide polygons. Okay. Anything
else? Let's check the Python API even
though I never use it. See, I do use it
sometimes but not that often. Okay,
that's fine. And then Oh, whoops. I
meant to click uh core. And then we'll
take a look at assets. Yep. Undo.
Windows animation and rigging. Let's see
what happened there.
Let's see.
Action. Shape keys evaluate a lot
faster. That's good.
Go. And then a ton of stuff like that.
Goshion smoothing. Let's take a look at
that.
Oh, so it's a modifier.
That is very cool to see. Indestructive.
That is very good. Wow.
See UI
colored. Ah, nice. And then let's see.
Show subframes is enabled. Oh, okay.
Okay.
See.
All right. That's good. And then assets.
Let's see. Individual libraries can be
disabled in the preferences, cataloges,
and uh that's because it would someone
mentioned that, but I forgot what that
did. Asset shelf. Yep. All that is good.
Okay. So, that's a brief overview of
everything in Pi.1.
Uh, let's check the chat again. Are
dynamics coming in Pi.1? No. [music]
No, they're not. It's It's taking It's
taking a while. See, would it be
possible to simulate fluids with surface
tension in grids, or would you need
particles for that? Uh, I honestly don't
know. I I just don't know,
unfortunately. I would assume that it
would probably be possible. Maybe not in
Blender because it well
it if it were possible, it would not be
fast at all.
But yeah,
but with the little bit of stuff we
have, it is quite cool. Oh, before if
you're wondering about like oh two
dimensional volumes, the volume cube
node
uh this the limit for the resolution was
set to two. And now with this we can set
it to one. I assume that's just a
technical limitation. If you try doing
that it's like no the res resolution
must be greater than one. But now they
don't have to be greater than one. I
could make this a 1x 256
thing. Oh, but of course it doesn't
actually show. Yep.
Did see something here at the very
least. Let's try 64.
Hello.
Ah, there we go. Okay. Uh, so it's Yeah.
relative or original? Uh, it sets to
original. So here we should see at least
something appearing, right?
Let's set that to be 32. There should be
again something.
There isn't.
So many voxels. I actually don't know
why that's not working.
Let's control Z until we get that back.
Maybe it's just the distance is 128.
So that works. Yeah, maybe it's just not
um that all too well. We go. We can see
all that and then that happens which is
cool.
256. I tried 512 512 but it is slow as
heck.
Yeah. Oh, and I need to adjust the voxil
uh division for some of the parts so
that does not turn into that.
But yes,
it's cool. We're getting simulation
capabilities.
Let's see.
I went to report a bug real bundle and
you already had it reported. Uh I did
not report a bug, but I made a PR about
it because I was like, "Oh, shoot. I
did." Unfortunately, when I made the
nodes, I did not check to see if the
bundle signature was something that was
automatically created, and they merged
the node before that was put in. Uh,
which means that on one hand, it 100%
has to be fixed, and it doesn't seem too
difficult to implement. I just need to
look through and see what functions are
automatically available and if there are
any functions that need to be
specifically created which I am not
exactly looking forward to. It's
possible. I just need to actually do it.
Okay. What are the specific use case use
cases you have in mind for lists? I'll
be using it for complex sorting
functions. I have a few. I'm glad you
asked. Let's go and get my PRs up.
So,
I'm just going to get the PRs.
So, let's see. Nameless and collection
children. So, with this one, I'm just
pulling up both of them on my browser.
And the data block name, we could
actually take a look at that live today.
I'm just postponing the actual project I
want to do today. And also I'm going to
get the uh
curve to node word ID uh curve to
string. There we go. So boop boop boop.
Welcome to another day of news in
Blender.
Okay. So let's
look at this. So the first one uh this
one will probably make it in 5.1. It's
basically just string to curves with
word ID outputs. Uh which is pretty
simple. It wasn't too difficult to
implement. This was discussed in a
module meeting, so I should um
check a few things. Added 31 lines of
code. I didn't think it Oh, right. No, I
forgot. Yeah, takes a little bit, but
it's not too bad. It's mainly just
copying what is already existing in
there. But let's take a look at the
lists. So the two nodes I have in mind
for that use list are the collection
children node which is was inspired by
one of Jack's Luke's uh branches where
he added an input to the collection info
node which had something like this and I
was like oh let me make a node that has
that and the OB or was it the objects or
just the collections? Well anyway this
one has both where you can just get all
that. Now I could I did not make a build
that has this at the moment so I can't
go and show the slide but you would just
input a collection and it would output
all the objects in that collection and
all these subolctions and you can press
recursive so it will look through all of
the subolctions.
So it's great very very useful when
dealing with giant uh I guess guess
pipeline kind of stuff where you just
have a collection and then all the
necessary parts in that collection. So
it's very very useful. I wonder if
there's going to be a list sort node
because that [music] would be very good.
I need to look into that. That that
wouldn't be difficult. I don't think
that that wouldn't be too difficult
assuming that it's string based.
Yeah, I'll need to think about that. But
speaking of string lists, uh the
attribute name list node. So at the
moment, uh the current approach to get
all the attributes is just to do it
manually, which oh I I did that.
I just X out of Firefox. Yes, I am a
genius. I saw an X button. I was like,
"Oh, I need to go and get that." Sorry,
one second everyone. I'm a genius when
it comes to browsers.
Nope, that is the wrong tabs. I'm going
to get back up. Ask all your questions
now while I am looking through things.
Ah, here we go.
And we are I'm back. There we go.
Attribute name list. where before you
would have to go and get the just
basically put them in manually which is
inconvenient and slow and not very
pipelinable but the proposed solution is
to get the attribute name lists from
there and output them there. Now during
a module meeting the devs were
not entirely sure what would be the best
way to adapt this to use strings the mo
in the most effective manner. Uh the
couple of options that were proposed
were to output like the name and then it
was another piece of data and then the
actual attributes as a bundle list which
seems like the most likely solution. So
you would need attribute list and then
separate bundle or get bundle item and
then separate bundle which is a bit
inconvenient or maybe all the lists
could just be output there but then you
would need several get list item nodes
which is also a little in inconvenient
but the current method that I have here
is just you get the names get list item
do that you can get the first UV map or
a armature deform
uh setup though it is much slower than
the default fault I'm assuming just
because of geometry nodes overhead which
seems to be fairly significant
but yeah and actually storing the
attributes with stored named attribute
nodes you probably can't see it all too
well and it's not letting me zoom in
anymore
storing them with stored named attribute
nodes is faster than just putting them
through a repeat zone without the
geometry which is weird but oh well
uh and then with all that yeah that
that's everything there. Someone put a
frowny face on there. H.
And then, yeah, there's just a lot of um
options there. Uh I'm also thinking
about putting in a the last thing I did
was put in a boolean input for filtering
or not filtering, but I have not figured
out how to make it hide the menus in
there, which I know is possible.
But yeah, that is the stuff. There will
be a list uh sort node. Uh I've seen it
in an included PR. Ah that's good. That
is good. Sorting the list and then like
filtering lists. That will be very very
useful. But yeah, that is that those are
my plans
and it will be good. It's just those
will not be in 5.1. Those will be in 5.2
because lists will not be in 5.1.
did not know that until uh
later last week.
But yes, now that we're back in the
Blender scene, I'm going to go and make
a new scene because I want to just go
and try a new little project.
So, let's see. Let's go into here. I'm
going to be using uh GPU displacement
and it will be fun. So, a while back,
uh, a buddy of mine was playing
Cyberpunk and there was a cool like
digital world scene and where everything
was like box that like stretched and
went down into the scene. You You'll
know it when I actually make it because
it is not difficult to make whatsoever.
I want to attempt making it and then I
can make it look all nice and pretty.
Something like that. I'm just going to
go to geo nodes, new. I'm going to
distribute points on faces.
distribute points on faces, instance on
points
and then I will realize the instances.
So just like this, I'm just going to
make a cool little project
because I'm just uh going quickly. Oh.
Oh, it automatically sets an ID now.
I did not know that.
Nice. Oh, that is that is great. Or
maybe I just couldn't see it before. I
don't remember seeing the um the IDs for
that. That is really really really
really good.
Oh, you love to see it. Uh okay. So now
I'm going to make a plane. I'm not sure
if I want to rotate this [music] towards
the camera or not or make it a
crisscross pattern. Not sure. I just
want it to be as fast as possible.
Which you may be wondering, wait, why
are you realizing the instances if you
want it to be as fast as possible? Well,
that's because um
realizing instances re uh renders
everything faster than if I were not to
do that. So, here I'm going to do this.
I'm going to change the world to be
completely black. I'm going to change
the color management to be aces 1.3.
Even though 2.0 might be a bit better. I
probably should just use 2.0, but h 1.3.
Yeah. Uh we'll do emission and
transparent. And then we don't need to
worry about the displacement. The
displacement will just be let me go and
move that over to there. I always use
the geonode uh workspace because it is
just the best out of the bunch. The
shader editor boots up Eevee
automatically which is not good
uh for speed. And this one also includes
the timeline which the shader editor
does. Uh the shader workspace does not.
We have this. We're going to do that.
We're going to do this. And I think for
the moment I'm just going to make this
kind of blue. Change this to be blended.
And since these are all in one level, we
don't need to worry about it lagging, I
think, because it didn't initiate a ton
of draw calls, I think, in order to do
that. But the real cool stuff is I'll be
using the UV map
to drive the displacement based on
distance. So, if I go and get the object
position, object info location, and then
get the length and [music] then add to
that length, then use a map range.
Uh, here we go. Map range.
We go smoother step vector math
multiply. There we go. Let's set that to
be 10. And I hook that into the
displacement kind of like geometry
nodes. We can see that all these parts.
Oh, right. because the location is not
actually stored there. I need to store
the location of the points
just so that there's no weird like
interpolation. So, vector uh position
just put that in there. Position
on buddy.
Go shader editor. Go back to the main
thing. Oh, right. The plane.
Uh, okay. So, we have all that. Let's go
and get the attributes. And it does not
need to be on the instancer
uh domain because everything is realized
which if you wanted it so that worked on
both levels you can just go into
instancer or that and then add the two
and it'll add whichever one is currently
available. But here if we take a look at
this we can see
but it doesn't look like the way it
should. So we can use the UV map to
offset the quote unquote time of the
effect. So here we can just use multiply
put that into there and that is the
incorrect one. Uh there we go. So we set
that to be 0.5 and then
Yep. That's like that. And I just need
to do I divide before or after? I think
before would be better. Set that to be
like five. There we go. So like So
we can see that that's pretty fast
because it's all GPU displacement
without a ton of draw calls. That is
pretty pretty cool. Pretty good. Now I
just need to make it look even better.
So we do that. We do that. Put that over
to there. Um
over to there. Put it over to there.
Bring this over to here.
Uh, okay. Now, let's go and get the UV
map and make this actually look good.
So, we can get the length.
Put that through a map range. Let me
just control V. Oh, you can also copy
nodes between Blender instances now in
5.1, which is so great. That's going to
make things so much better for everyone.
Uh, let's go and use the LG lightfall
thing, which has carried my entire
career, and I don't know why it works at
this point. I don't know why I made it
like this, but it just works and I don't
question it.
And that
uh distance
0.5 just so that we get the middle and
then we just need to multiply you so
that ah there we go. I just need to add
in some bloom and then we're going to
get the coolest looking thing on the
planets. And maybe I should add in some
general variation
for the stuff. But just look at that.
Then I need to make the gradient um
disappear when it gets to the top, which
is pretty easy. I just need to use a map
range again.
Put that into there. And then we just
use mix or multiply. I'll I'll just do a
mix so that I don't need to worry about
it.
Go at the top. Yes, we can see. Even
though maybe that should be like 0.5
and 75. There we go. Then maybe 0.25.
There we go. That's better. So it's like
and I should probably store a random
value for each island so that I can add
in some randomness
and maybe also make it so that this is
the plane is a crisscross so that it
doesn't look weird from other angles.
Yeah, there we go. So now it's just a
little bit better. So once I get the
random data stored on there and it's all
just cached so it doesn't need to update
automatically
right here. We do that make it a flow
and make this random.
Add in a random value right there. We
put this there. We move this up to
there. We look in the shader editor.
Go. We go to the plane again. I should
just have the as well so that I don't
need to look through both
both. So, let's do this just to make
this a little bit easier to work
through. I find that I'm liking the kind
of vertical stack method of organizing
nodes.
Not entirely sure why cuz it can look a
little bit messy.
Seems to work. So, random. We need to
subtract 0.5 before we multiply just to
make it so that it's not normalized or
it goes in the positive and negative
directions.
Right there. Make this another little
vertical stack. And then we plug it into
there. So one operation per kind of
back. Do that. Place that in there. We
can put that in there as well, which is
very nice. And then for the origin part
here, we can just go and collapse some
of these nodes and do that, which is
nice. Here we can see there's a bit of
randomness. And we can make that a lot
more or a lot less. So I think two is
fine.
I think that's fine. Let's go in the
compositing and add in a little bit. Oh,
the compositor tab changed. We're here.
Uh, it doesn't show there, but it shows
up there, which actually I don't mind. I
don't mind at all. Uh, let's go. I'm
actually going to save this. One second,
everyone.
Cuz I forgot to save
file. Save. I had a crash when I tried
to render or do compositing without an
actual rendered image. So I'm just being
a little cautious. So this will be uh
net shader or something like that. Let's
go render one thing. Let's take a look.
Okay. So that's like that. So the new uh
compositor editor which I think looks
pretty cool. Let's go back into here.
Have this in the viewport always. And
that is looking pretty cool. Very very
cool.
All right. So with that we can go and
change this to whatever color we want.
Oh, that is that's looking quite cool. I
can uh basically do whatever.
Oh, also one thing that I was like I
should try adding this to the shader
editor cuz constants I think are allowed
now. I actually need to ask about that,
but there's no shots making it to 5.1.
The scene time node, I really want that
in the shader editor.
I do not know how to do it, but I really
want to try. But there there's no shot
of that making it into 5.1. I thought I
had more time. It's the the deadline is
this week or wait, no, next week. Today,
Saturday.
But yeah, I really uh
5.2 5.2. If I want to get one thing in
there, it will be the scene time node.
No matter what I have to do
that and the texture socket. Well, Jax
is already working on that.
Okay.
So, yep, we have all that. And then I
need to add in a little bit of ambient
animation for when these are on the
ground.
So, that's just the general
displacement.
And I could add in another
put this over to here cuz this is the
actual.
See, you can use hashtag frame instead
of key framing or the same time node. I
know about hashtag frame, but as mod has
said right there,
hashtag frame, everyone uses it because
it's the most convenient, but you
shouldn't because well, I'm not going to
say you shouldn't because it's basically
the only good convenient way of doing
it.
The attribute methods like using uh the
attribute node, it doesn't work in
cycles. Sometimes I've tried where it's
like view layer and then you get d
something something
and sometimes it doesn't update because
of dependency graph stuff. Maybe they
fixed it. But a scene time node would be
the only it would be the solution.
Hashtag frame is the only way people
actually do it these days. But it's not
the best. Scene time node is very
necessary, but it's uh
the shader editor needs a a bit of work
before it's implemented, but it's a very
it needs to be in sync with every other
editor in Blender. Now, the compositor
has it because it's just easier to
implement it there.
It's has it for has had it for years at
this point. I think multiple years
actually. I could check that right now.
Just got to get VS Code up on the side
and then I'll be able to see
Windows
is lagging.
It's not allowing me to search.
Windows 11 is being uh kind of weird.
But long story short, um, #frame, it
it's about time we abandoned the weird
driver method because it's just slow.
Uh, okay. What did I want to do? I
wanted to change the lighting here,
which Oh, that actually that works very
well for
bit of randomness.
Pretty cool. Pretty nice.
Then let me just go and animate this
from start to finish. Actually,
best way to do it is to just have a
value that goes from zero to one and
then you map range it after just so that
you don't need to keep changing the
actual animated values all the time.
I'll switch that to be a subtract node.
So the start needs to be something like
that and the end.
Change this to linear as well. I love
the colors in there.
Uh, and then that has to be like that.
So with that, we can see turn off
temporal reprojection. Always turn that
off. Always turn that off.
I I've I've know I' I know I've been a
critic about Eevee next, but I've I've
started to learn a bit more about it.
And if you have denoising off, it's
actually not that bad. Like if you have
den noising off, precision one,
thickness set to two, resolution set to
one of one, which is the only way you
can actually render things well without
having denoising on.
And then fasti approximation, you could
keep that on or off. Just make sure it's
like 0.5, but turning it off can help in
some situations. With the shadows, keep
the res resolution at 0.25 so that it
doesn't lag your machine to hell. And
then uh with the shadows changing this
doesn't really affect too much besides
again the resolution light threshold
that's all fine for the render samples
if you don't have ray tracing on 64 is
like the minimum to get an okay result.
So basically with EV next my opinion on
it. This is just my opinion. If they fix
the deninoiser and make it so that it's
not a
um [clears throat]
noisy a blurred noisy muddy result.
It would be a lot it would be pretty
good. Bounce lighting is quite nice
but yeah
I sometimes ruins the render. Uh yeah.
So when in doubt, just disable
everything. All the fast things because
it it it compromises the quality a the
denoising
really compromises reflections
horrifically, especially if you're using
metals. So never have bilateral filter
on. Temporal accumulation, try to have
that off all the time. Spatial reuse,
turn it off if you feel like you can get
away with it in your scene. Even though
spatial reuse is like the least bad
option out of the bunch, just never
usually don't have these two on if you
want a not super blurry result.
Yeah. And it doesn't look smooth. It
looks muddy because it's just blurring
the noise in a weird way. But with that
out of the way, and then the shadows are
very expensive in EV Next. Just keep the
resolution at 0.25. it doesn't change
the visual result all too much if you're
using somewhat soft shadows.
So basically there's a way to make it
work. And also for each light in the
scene make sure you turn on jittered
shadows because they are more accurate.
The other the default leads to lots of
light leaking though it does hurt the
res the render time by about 35%.
So yeah, be honest, I was disappointed
when the devs revealed ray tracing was
going to be screen spaced. They plan on
making it so that it will not be screen
space, but with how expensive screen
space uh rays are, I think there would
be need to be a massive speed up before
ray tracing would be anywhere close to
computationally viable compared to
cycles.
It's uh it's a bit rough on the speed
side.
Yeah, that that's another
another episode in my critiques of EV
Next cuz it it has
it has been a bit rough in my attempts
at using it in personal and professional
projects.
It's been rough.
But anyway, I do like the displacement,
though. Keep in mind that displacement
only is not an option in EV next. That's
only available in cycles. Even though I
wish it was an option. I hope that's
implemented one day. One day.
Yeah.
But that out of the way, let's go and
add in some displacement to these points
here. Cuz right now with this
displacement, this is com this is not
viable whatsoever for
objects that are not emissive. because
with displacement and bump, it'll go and
make everything look weird if these were
solid. If it were dis displacement only,
it wouldn't be a problem. But we just
don't have that ability at the moment.
Uh, okay. Let's go. What was I going to
Let's just have this here. Or no, let's
make this one dimension to make this as
fast as possible. Bring this the random
into there. I should multiply this by a
lot. or maybe even white noise it, but
that might not be the best idea
by 10. Right here, we can go and turn
off normalize and then add that to our
displacement right here.
Add plug that into there. Plug that into
there. I should go and scale the output
there. We should use the scene time
node. Oh, wait. That doesn't exist. Use
hashtag frame because that is the only
convenience thing here. I apologize mod.
I do not remember the recommended way of
actually doing it using the attribute
inputs, but they also they do not work
in cycles because of the dependency
graph. It's weird.
Uh let's go and divide this by bits.
Um
go.
It's one of those cases where there
should be a better option available, but
there just isn't because of limitations
in the shader editor. Again, just like
the texture socket input where the
workaround is using a closure and then a
texture and then doing that, which it
leads to um cool results. But the having
just a texture input
while it's being worked on, it should be
um
a little bit more convenient.
So, we have that. Let's go and divide
that by 200. So, here we have all these
moving around like little fireflies.
Oh, yeah. That's pretty cool. I'm not
sure. I don't think they actually move
in the game. Again, I was just watching
it on a uh
a stream that my friend was doing, so I
did not get to see it uncompressed and
everything.
As we can see,
it's not bad. Do we turn the detail down
or up? That down's fine. And then that
it just looks like
I think like that's better. The kind of
firefly look, but we can still use
random
into a color ramp.
Oh, I wonder if the
I wonder if the closure subtypes will be
added in 5.1. I kind of doubt it cuz I
haven't seen any work on I haven't heard
any news on that PR in a while. That
would be so good if we got that, but
probably 5.2 too. If not,
we have that. So, we can just pick the
colors
there
and right there. That's That's pretty
cool.
So, now I just need to get a somewhat
interesting looking cityscape.
And again, this is a fairly okay, maybe
not the simplest setup, but
you just get do a bit of vector math and
then it can act like a geo nodes to a
degree. Again, it's super fast because
we're offloading
all the dynamic computations onto the
GPU, which is great.
If I were to use the actual position or
no wait, it's using the random part
there.
Oh yeah. Uh what else? What else do I
want to do? So we have all that and that
I almost want to make it so that these
all extend downwards
and take a look at that. So over here
that
there
and then doing that.
Oh, I'm sensing a bit of lag even though
it shouldn't be lagging too much.
Oh yeah, now it's lagging. Let me go and
turn shadows down to 0.25 just in case.
There shouldn't be any shadows in the
scene.
And I feel the lag go away.
Funnily enough, if you turn off shadows,
I noticed a performance hit. So having
it on is better even if you have it like
the resolution down to whatever.
So, I could still do that, but it looks
Well, it looks cool. It's That kind of
looks a bit weird.
Uhoh, it's a lagging. It's lagging. Oh
no.
No, it's not actually lag.
It just zoomed out really far for some
reason.
Uh oh. What if I made this green?
That's pretty cool. Oh, also I need a
white noise this so that the
the um colors do not coincide with the
the small uh orbs.
That's just so that I can randomize the
colors very easily. So just like add
plug that into there and then I can
easily randomize all that. But in this
case, having a seed value of basically
zero is okay.
So maybe something like that. A nice
green and cool blue.
I think that's pretty cool. I think that
works quite well. We don't have
instancing on the GPU
or like just scattering on the GPU, but
that would be cool as well cuz these
could also be points because in
you can't displace points in cycles, but
you can in Eevee, which I wish we could
displace points in cycles. That would be
very, very nice, but alas, we cannot
last time I checked.
That would be such a cool environment to
see like in VR just looking around. It's
just like wow pretty. Hopefully not too
computationally expensive. Even though
alpha plus VR does not work well
if remember correctly. It's been a while
since I've tried VR stuff.
Yeah, there we go.
Let's have this and then it lays out an
entire scene.
Everything is possible if you have a
good enough imagination.
in the scene time node in the shader
editor.
So, I could make these any shape I want.
I think it's like what what do I want?
Do I want it to just be square or a
little bit of that? Could add in a bit
of noise just to make it look a bit
cooler. But I do kind of like the star
shape right there.
And also, in theory, I could make these
face towards the camera. Or actually,
can I? Potentially, I could potentially
make these face towards the camera, but
that would be very annoying to do on the
GPU with the shader editor, but I think
it's fine. We're at 48 minutes. Okay, so
the timing is working out quite well cuz
the effect is basically done. I can just
go and make it so that Oh, what kind of
shape do I want? Do I want a echosphere
with these as well? Cuz that's possible,
too. just like
and boom, you have your scene laid out
like that. It's almost like working with
gajon splats
just like oh you just have points and
you can move them around
like that and then again it looks quite
cool. Quite cool. Oh, we have 36 people
here. 41 people here. It just
automatically updated. How about that?
Why are you all here? Uh, but welcome.
Welcome. I'm going to wrap things up
pretty cool. Uh, pretty quickly.
We go. I don't know what else to do.
Again to summarize the effect, it's
basically just instancing a little plane
on points, realizing the instances, then
using the data stored in here to uh
basically do displacement in the shader
editor. It's uh that's the stuff.
So sad I missed the beginning, but you
can just rewatch it. You can just
rewatch it. It'll be fine.
That looks cool.
At least try. I don't know why, but this
is this is giving my brain like Netflix
intro vibes. Maybe it's just because the
vertical things there. Um, let them
collide and bounce. That would be very
difficult to implement though. my easing
functions which I have not ported to the
shader editor yet. But I could go and do
something like load curve
which
uh I could do something like because
this is inverted.
Is it? Let's just try this
that that and that. So here
uh there we go.
Here, I could make them just bounce when
they fall, but it unless it were highly
randomized, it wouldn't look that great.
Uh, well, let's let's give it a shot.
It's like that. Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Uh, when closure subtypes become a
thing, we may get the like easing
handles on these, which would be so
nice. I want that so bad.
And with motion blur, uh, little tip, if
you want to do motion blur with alpha
blend things, you just need to turn up
the substeps. The actual blur will not
happen on alpha blend stuff because it
only realizes real meshes.
So, if you have an object moving, why do
we have 56 people here? Why do why why
are you all showing up? I don't get it.
Um, guess I need to actually make this
interesting now. Yeah, let's add in uh
some more shapes just to make this look
uh cooler. Let's add in a donut in the
sky cuz that looks cool.
Yeah, that that looks cool. Let me also
get the camera set up. Uh if you have a
real mesh or material moving in back of
alpha plane stuff, it the motion blur
will affect the alpha plane.
Also, I recently learned during my
projects that um depth of field does not
get motion blurred. It will do the
motion blur first and then
the al uh then the depth of field which
can make it look like your motion blur
is not applying. So, just turn up the
steps to like three. Anyway,
see, I've been waiting for 5.1. Finally,
the video editor and compositor are
getting some love. In 5.0, 0 the video
editor and compositor got a huge update
which I'm so happy about
that this looks so cool. I just feel
like it needs a little bit more like I
need to scale the
like I need to scale these parts
randomly which I could do because again
this side is only on the CPU. I can add
in a random value. This does not
recalculate every frame. If the mesh
doesn't move, all this is still
performance. Very good for performance.
Here I can set that to be that that do
that. So that's 0.25.
So I can have something like this. And
then
so cool. So cool. Uh let's see. Did you
join uh did you see Netflix join the
Blender development fund? I did. And if
anyone's concerned about that, you
should not be because it's the deal is
basically Netflix gives Blender money
and that's it.
Uh, as far as I know, there are no
strings attached. Adobe has been even
donating to Blender already. Blender is
just becoming very important uh
infrastructure for visual effects or
just animation and visual effects in
general. So, you should not be scared
about that. Oh. Oh, that that I like
that. That's cool.
That is cool. Oh, and I could also make
it so that the the noise is scaled by
the thing as well. Oh, it's starting to
lag now, though. May maybe I'm overdoing
the amount of uh mesh planes. If we set
that to be like 10, we can see
then set that to be one. It's like that.
Okay.
It it doesn't look okay. Looks okay, but
not the best if I'm being honest. These
would need more subdivisions, which I
could try, but I'm a little worried
about the speed. We're kind of hitting
the Oh my gosh,
we're kind of hitting the limit of um
uh what's efficient with all this.
Actually, the subdivisions
aren't doing anything there. Thought it
would. Oh, right. Because the noise
texture is not location based.
If this were location based,
um, it would look very different. Maybe
better, maybe worse. I'm actually not
sure, but let's let's give it a shot
in this case.
Okay, we can see we can see it looks a
little bit different. Maybe I need to
adjust the scale. So that's a little
more
one. There we go. So here it's a bit
more like bit more warped, bit cooler.
But I think the default is fine. Let's
not even scale it. I think it's fine
regardless.
I think that's everything for today. We
are at 55 minutes, so I think I'll go
and uh wrap things up.
Uh if you have any last questions about
Blender 5.1 or you know just Blender
stuff in general, ask them now.
Oh, and I could also store the normals
for all this can lead to some cool
shader effects. So since the normal is
stored when you distribute points on
faces, I could go and store that here.
Let's just make this norm
and plug that into there.
Go. Let's go to the shader editor and
get that attributes which is the norm.
I'm also looking forward to when we get
like string inputs in the shader editor
so that we can go and like have string
inputs here and for especially the UV
tangent node because I have a node
group.
Uh because where's the
where's the
tangent? Which one is it?
math input tangent because this one has
a UV map input, but you cannot access
this from inside a node group. I have a
node group that uses this, but um yeah,
we need we need the ability to input
that from outside. Oh, and I need to
show you my data block to string node
that I'm working on. That will not be in
5.1, but maybe it'll be um later. So,
here I can go and get the normals of all
this. So if something is pointing up
something like that, I can now harvest
that data which also if I go and shade
smooth it uh smooth shades that data as
well that can be used for very
interesting effects as well. So if I
were to go into the shader editor
and then use the norm to affect the
color. I'm just going to put in the dot
product. There
we go. You can go and make it like that.
Or conversely, conversely,
something like that. And we bring the
shadows down to something like that.
Have something like that. I could also
map range this to make it look even
cooler.
But yeah, basically I want to keep it
dark, but not too dark. But yeah, if you
want a representation of a donut or
anything like that, you can go and do
that. just getting data, storing it, and
then using it in the shader editor. But
for now, oh, that actually that looks
cool, too.
So much is possible in
that. That's very cool. So, again, just
taking a look at this. It's just
all that appears.
That would be a cool post. Though I need
to make the background a little more
visually interesting. If I were to go
and join the initial geometry to the
fold,
it will have a different material. So,
it shouldn't with everything else at
least in theory.
That do that. Turn this down. And also,
oh, right. There is a light in there. We
do that. That can make things look a
little bit
Okay. I do like how it collides. Like it
makes everything not super visible. Oh,
wait. I can use the Yeah, let's not do
that.
But if I go No, I can't ray cast.
The raycast node is not in 5.1.
Yeah. No, it's not.
could get the vector to the camera and
then dot product dotproduct that with
the normal to basically get a frenel.
But no, I could actually get the frenel
node and input the normal that I desire.
So if I go and use a or layer weight
node would be a little bit better in
this case. So that plug the normal into
there. Take a look at this. We can see
that we're getting a pseudo or yeah just
for now using the normal that we stored.
Then we can use that for the layer
weight. And then with that as well,
see that we're getting make it making it
look like it has some actual volume to
it.
But if I did that,
h I would be able to get the back facing
things. If I were to subtract with the
current position of the camera, which if
I'm being honest, how do I go and do
that? I need to get the attributes.
need to get the view layer thing and
then I need to get the location of you
which the full data path
bring it into here
location no not location one this should
be
ah there we go okay so we can subtract
that with the position
dangif almost 50 people here I am
shocked but with this we can get the
vector to the camera we need normalize
this as well so that the vectors have a
length of one. We do that and that then
we dotproduct it that we should get a
gradient that is facing the camera
almost like the Fresnel
if I did it correctly which I think I
need to invert those two. There we go.
Yep, we can see that this is facing the
camera. So it almost looks like a light
is shining there which it won't actually
collide with the objects because it's
not an actual raycast. we can't detect
when something is actually hitting.
Let's see.
And then yeah, so this basically makes
it so that we can see a pseudo shadow
even though it again will not collide
with everything else in the scene. And
also this is kind of how you get um
I guess like a completely linear uh FEL
even though I think if you were to set
that to one that would be pretty much
but what I want is the negative values
so that I can go and play around with
that in here.
Basically making the parts that are in
the back invisible essentially. So if I
were to go and scale
the things there.
You can see that we are basically
getting
we're basically oluding the back face as
well of all these even though again
it's not 100% accurate as we can see
there
actually wait it shouldn't be show oh
because of the yeah I shade auto smooth
I shade auto smooth and then we put this
before else yeah there we go to be like
It will it'll include everything that's
not like facing the right way. Basically
is back facing.
Need you in there. Yep. That is that
again.
Works pretty well. If we move the
camera, everything will work as
intended.
But I think we need to use a map range
instead because I want to go and play
around with some of the values.
Also, I want to plug you into there
because I want to see what a linear
falloff looks like with all that. Yep,
that looks exactly as expected. We're
over an hour. I need to uh wrap this up
really quickly.
I'm still preferring the just golden
orange look like the the sunrise orange.
25. And then again, I can make it so
that the back is actually shown but just
toned down. do that and that we can see.
Yep. More opposite it goes, the more it
looks like that right there. It looks
like that. But it's all too necessary.
Maybe 0.25 to.25
would be good.
I think that's uh I think that's
acceptable. Then for the actual color,
well, I'm just going to disable that cuz
I really like the golden orange.
Actually, no. that I'll need to play
around with it a little bit.
Still like the just if we get the
Z-axis.
That one does look good. One does look
good. Even though I could map range to
make it look a little bit different
than right there.
H
do I do? And then if I do that, we can
make this a little more generalized.
do whatever I want in this world because
again, it's a nice little sandbox. I
like playing in the little sandbox
instead of having a computer do it for
me. Got to take on AI. Whoop.
There we go. Like playing in the digital
sandbox.
The green looks good. I always need to
turn on I need to make a little script
that always um sets the asper out to be
fully opaque just because I need to see
what the viewport actually finally sees.
Don't it's just
that ruins everything.
Get the wrong expectations of the frame
and then when I render I'm like no it
shouldn't look like that.
Actually I like that. Maybe HSV mode.
Make it very rainbow
just like uh the new Tamadachi life.
See,
I'm liking the greens. The The greens
are looking good.
No,
I am liking the greens, though.
Maybe keeping these going just
vertically would be good. Oh, I need to
try making them just go horizontal.
Oh, that's just the matrix filter.
Just the matrix filter there. It's like
Oh, that's it almost works, but since
the uh the other displacement is going
vertical, that um or the UV is going
vertical, that doesn't mesh all too
well. Let's try that way.
It does look a bit weird with uh the
tops and bottoms doing that.
Yeah, I think vertical is the way to go.
Or what we had before where it was just
um
a really trippy
where it was just like
Extreme
perspective works well. So yeah, green
is an option. Let me go and just put
that to the side. Let's go and get the
very nice looking
oranges there. Looks a little bit too
detailed, so I need to find a way of
making that look better. Also need to
try Okay, the blues always look good.
Uh, okay. And the only other thing I'm
going to try for now, this will be the
last thing.
Um,
see,
let me read the chat again.
Trying to hear the logic behind
Geonotes. The decision making process
described perfectly in your streams.
That's why we're here. Oh, I'm glad. I'm
glad. Let's see. But they start to
complain and retract funds. I hope the
foundation will not bend under the
demands. I a lot of corporate sabotage
with white gloves happening with the
open software. I doubt that'll be the
case. Especially if they go after
Blender, there will be a lot of negative
press and I don't think they would enjoy
that. I wonder what their demands would
be. I wonder what they would be
as someone who has well I cannot say
never mind complete. Uh forget that
thought.
I have a little bit of insight into the
corporate uh and Blender ties, but not
too much. But it has not been bad. Has
not been bad. Make that two dimensions
because we're using the UV map.
Not with Netflix. I need to specify that
to add in a little bit of warbling.
Oh yeah. No, that Oh, that helps a bit.
And then I can animate that by going up,
down, side to side using the scene time.
Oh, wait. We don't have that. Using the
hashtag frame. I'm going to make that
into a node group
because if you copy something with the
driver, it does not copy.
So basically having a se
# frame node group unfortunately is the
way to go. Unfortunately,
h I I I I need to get that in there
somehow. I do not know the shader editor
code. I was looking at the texture node
and the old texture node. It is so old.
It's from 2005
and uh
2005.
There we go. Yeah, a little bit of wispy
stuff looks cool as well, making it look
very warbly. I guess again, my only
complaint with this at the moment is
that it looks too detailed with
everything going on. I need to make it
less detailed. Also, I should also Oh,
no. The UV map is actually stored
automatically because it's a named
attribute. So, UV map. If I go and take
a look at that, we can see. Yep. The Oh,
wait. No, I need to make the name
different because there's a name
collision
here. I'll just make this UV map one.
So, that when it's accessed here, it'll
go and get the Yeah. the underlying UV
map of the mesh. So, a lot is
can be done here. Use depth of field
with your camera. That does not work
with uh alpha blend unless I use the
jitter depth of field which will take so
many samples to actually uh
implement but I'll give it a shot. So
here we can see that the depth of field
does not appear to be working. That's
simply because it doesn't actually know
where to go. So if I go to depth of
field and jitter camera,
it will make it so that it works. But I
need to turn the blur down to basically
zero.
So the max size needs to be zero.
Then
hello. Oh, and because of EV next again,
jitter depth of field is not visible in
the viewport. It's only visible in the
render unlike with EV legacy where you
could see that in the thing. So if I do
that, we can see that it renders in 1.73
seconds.
Yeah, which is a little expensive for
something with no shadows
is only alpha blend. Oh, if you turn
shadows off, it changes it from
again, these are shadows where it's
hitting nothing.
It changes it to 0.15 seconds. Uh, no.18
seconds.
So again, shadows are the most expensive
part of Eevee. Next, so keep those as
low as you can possibly have them.
Again, yeah, keep them as low because
they are just extremely expensive even
if they're not hitting anything.
Yeah, depth of field. That helps. Yep.
Even though it needs quite a few
samples, it does help.
And I'll just need to hone that in
because we cannot see it in the
viewports. It is so annoying compared to
EP Legacy. I know I complain about a
lot. I need to stop doing that.
But it since I still I still use Blender
4.1 for EV Legacy, which is why the
comparisons between the two are always
on the brain. I do need to apologize for
that. I need to stop complaining about
that. I need to stop complaining.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
I think for now I'll turn it off just so
that the two match.
Yeah. Here we have that going. And then
we have the wispy stuff happen. We have
50 viewers still.
Dang. Okay.
So, yeah, this good enough for today.
I'll probably just edit the mesh off
stream to make it look a bit better.
Maybe like a cityscape or something like
that. I do like the wisp effect. Let's
try just a few more colors
before I go for the day. So again, that
looks good. That also looks good.
I think I think the blues have it. The
blues always have it. But the purples
though, look at that. AGX color
clipping. Ooh, yep. That's why people
say that ASUS uh or [music] AGX is the
best. ASUS 2.0 causes there to be much
less color clipping.
That Oh,
AGX makes things very washed out, but
apparently it's just more accurate to
our eyes. And then I could use the
compositor with the
Nope, that's the wrong one. the tune
image node and then do a color boost.
Hello.
Oh, the color boost did not nothing.
Oh,
I would uh I thought that would help.
H clarity and then detail, you know, if
you want to make it look super deep
fried, always an option. Okay. But for
now, because for this shot, it looks
better. I'm going with Aces 1.3. Then
there's Filmic as well, which uh doesn't
look as good. So, Aces 1.3 has become my
new best friend.
Let's go and control Z until we're back
to there.
Mm is gone. Aces 1.3 is my new best
friend.
All right.
So, let's read the chat and then uh
we'll go for the day.
How many viewers do you usually have
during a live stream? I would say it's
around the like 24 amount.
Like maybe two years ago it like I think
it reached like 75 at the max which was
cool. I'm not a I'm not a YouTuber. I'm
not a live streamer. I just do this
occasionally to share the knowledge and
people enjoy the interactivity. So it's
the best medium to share my work. People
like seeing the live uh problem solving
that I do. you think there will be some
improvements to texture baking? People
have requested it in the survey. They
know, the devs know about it, but
uh we'll see. I haven't seen any PRs
about it. For me personally,
like I don't think too much needs to be
changed about it beyond it needs to
output the metallic and roughness passes
and have like a batch like every single
pass output to a file path. that needs
to go. Filmic's gone. No, filmic is
still in there. It's just I prefer uh
the other methods. So, with the baking
again, they just need to incorporate
some of the stuff that the add-ons have.
The add-ons are good
and yeah, it's just that and GPU
acceleration and you know, all the other
stuff. Baking just needs a few tweaks to
make it actually usable cuz the previous
versions are not not great. The pre the
the current baking method is not great.
It's quite ancient. Probably over a
decade old as well. Maybe like 15 years,
I would assume. It's gotten some updates
here and there like under the hood under
the hood changes, but nothing don't
think anything user pacing, but I would
have to check.
But I would imagine
with the open source development thing,
you just need one person to be annoyed
enough to learn how it works to update
it.
That's that's basically me with geometry
nodes and several other developers with
just like little bits here and there
with Blender. You just need to get
someone annoyed enough where they
actually start messing with the source
code assuming that they actually know
what they're doing cuz uh yeah,
some people just are like, "Hey AI, make
Blender do this." And then they up they
try to do a PR and it gets shot down.
Don't do that. Just don't. Let's see
another way instead of the driver and
the key frame. Uh wait an another way
instead of the driver
to key frame the value of one and
another key frame of two and then oh and
then do the like infinite interpolation.
Yeah, but that's very annoying to set
up. That takes like probably 30 seconds
versus hashtag frame. We just need the
scene time node in the shader editor.
That's the solution that should exist.
All right. Thank you for sharing. Best
way to learn geo nodes for sure. Ah, I'm
glad. I'm glad. All right. Thank you all
for watching. I hope you all enjoyed. I
think I read everything. But yes,
Blender 5.1 is going to be quite good.
There are improvements across the board.
5.2 will have may will probably have uh
lists and geometry nodes, which I have
plans for as well. But yeah, 5.1 is
looking pretty good. Uh yeah, go have
fun with it. I'll see you all next time.
Have a good one.